ale a tutti ragazzi venuti a questo
momento
basta basta bella tutti ragazzi
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj volevo
ringraziarvi in apertura del blog perché
haters in italia ha raggiunto 5 milioni
di visualizzazioni tempo record
manco gabbani troppo cioè non pensavo
mai andasse così troppo bene grazie
grazie grazie ai ter parte questo volevo
raccontare un po del fatto che la scorsa
settimana sono successe un miliardo di
cose e come sapete ogni tanto io nei
blog metto tutto insieme faccio vedere
tutte le cose che sono successe durante
la settimana partiamo dal fatto che
marco merlino mentre lui sembra in mezzo
e sempre in mezzo questo è venuto a casa
mia e ha portato la nintendo switch e
allora abbiamo caseggiato un po che
questo il risultato
ciao ragazzi noi stiamo provando la la
nintendo switch che è una è una bella
non so che ti darà dei giochi che ti
intrattengono ne sono belli
belli e tranquilli fantastico mi piace
un sacco e max ma manca marco è venuto
qua oggi e mi ha detto di provare questi
giochi devo cullare questo bambino
finché non si addormenta su ciò che io
non sono abituato a fare queste cose
bello a un multiplayer
[Risate]
quando vai col dire cosa ho visto
oddio ma dei pasto 98 e tre quarti a noi
mezzo
al servizio pre gara e poi di ripetere
il parere di aprire devono fare tutto
questo ragazzi siamo arrivati ad un
punto in cui vi spiego una cosa allora
la girella che non so se la conosceva
bene le brioche quelle che mangia mi ha
mangiato se non hai mangiato ma girella
nella tua vita non sei una persona degna
mi ha contattato per informarvi di
questo contest sto parlando tutto
forbito e per fare bella figura con
girella è che so parlare bene riempitevi
di brioche già organizzando un contest
mi è andato anche il pacchetto che
sarebbe questo è da questo questo il
pacchetto questo è il caso del contest
che ho staccato brutalmente dal
pacchetto perché io sono tutto rude o le
scatole di girella potete vincere lover
board questo qua con un codice che
trovate dentro il dentro il pacchetto
entro la scatola io ad esempio trovato
questo che devo grattare così che non vi
farà ovviamente vedere perché se lo
vinco io lo stage epa che ve lo dovrete
mettere sul sito di girella che vi
lascio in descrizione potreste vincere
appunto lover board poi comunque sul
sito sotto trovate tutto il regolamento
completo spiegato nel dettaglio hanno
deciso di mandarmi
dover board per farvelo vedere non sono
responsabile di quello che state per
vedere non lo sono riuscito benissimo
molto bravo sei perfetto hai una questa
baby così come il 30 e girare e rigirare
ma tu sei chef la mia energia
adesso si vive di dio viaggi in 40 g
e in questo senso uno slogan gira meglio
con girella che si mangia girella gigolò
per board sono già guarda al serio e
credibile o overboard a parte che tra
l'altro adesso ho imparato a usare
perché quella clip l'ho registrata un po
aree socio non più skillato parti questo
scorsa settimana siamo andati a roma per
un evento è registrato un po di
backstage e un po di cose che sono
successe lì e quindi let's do facciamo
al video che ha fatto milioni di views
misura joker picchia step milioni grazie
delle milioni di views regolano le
persone con gli occhi state sito sito
stiamo lanciando i pupazzi ci ritornano
indietro non si sa per quale motivo
arcano ma ci rilanciano indietro i più
bassi
non so chi sia guarda
beh l'ho preso
prima
konami
a
aiuta ma non fatelo mai le mani giuseppe
[Musica]
va bene adesso ai scherzato facciamo
serio e non ti aspetto in braccio mi
sono allenato per anni ma certo si
disegna e quindi oggi ho qui joker e
ragazzi oggi vinciamo perché vanno
smentire che insieme
ecco di aiuto non valesse più schifo ma
l'amerina in ballo per i raid degli anni
e tempura è cotta a puntino come fosse
un tantino dove fa gli auguri a papà
perché la festa del papà tra trenta
secondi bordello
[Musica]
per il mio compleanno il piano maschera
[Applauso]
lippi deve essere che gli auguri di papa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e cosa devo dire gentile io non sono mai
buone o nessuno
[Applauso]
l'attesa è nervoso oggi come dialogano a
cena gli italiani vogliono mediare non
accenna agli italiani con altri blogger
va bene ragazzi questo è più o meno
quello che è successo durante la
settimana è stata una bella settimana
cadute con logo air board a parte e
niente ragazzi andate tutti ad
aggiornare il video di haters in italia
che arriviamo a 10 milioni e poi c'è la
[ __ ] davanti alla porta grazie quindi
raga spero che vi sia cresciuto come al
solito subito piaciuto nel momento mi
piace anche i vari social come
descrizione senza tesi d'ischia temi ci
rivediamo il prossimo video della
ragazza
[Musica]